So in the last 24 to 48 hours, we were told
that despite having Corona virus, Donald Trump
plans to be at next week's debate with Joe
Biden, which would be the second presidential
debate scheduled for Thursday.
Donald Trump, however, said this morning that
he is bailing out on the second presidential
debate with Joe Biden and will not participate
after the Commission on Presidential Debates
decided that because of health recommendations
in light of Donald Trump being a corona virus
super spreader.
Those are my words, not the words of the Commission
on Presidential Debates.
They decided to move debate number two to
a remote debate rather than do it in person.
Frank Fahrenkopf, who's the head of the debate
commission, told CNN they made this decision
themselves.
It wasn't a decision made with the presidential
candidates, but they made it based on recommendations
from the Cleveland Clinic, which advises the
CPD on health related issues in light of Corona
virus.
The statement put out by the CPD says that,
quote, These second presidential debate will
take the form of a town meeting in which the
candidates would participate from separate
remote locations.
Well, Donald Trump does not like it.
He was interviewed this morning by Fox Business
host Maria Bartiromo.
Trump says he's feeling great and he will
not do a debate via remote teleconference
or video.
Thank you so much for being here.
First question is, how are you feeling?
How is the first lady feeling this morning?
She's feeling good.
I'm feeling good.
Really good.
I make it perfect.
And we're ready to go.
I'm ready to go.
Except the quarantine situation to go for
a little while after you get tested or whatever
the procedure is.
But I'm ready to do looking forward to doing
the rallies.
I heard that the commission a little while
ago changed the debate style, and that's not
acceptable to us.
I beat him easily in the first debate, according
to the polls that I've seen, but I beat him
easily.
I felt I beat him easily.
I think he felt it, too.
It wouldn't answer any questions.
And he had the protection of Chris Wallace
all night long.
It was a stray thought.
Other Chris Wallace was a disaster.
But I beat him in the first debate.
At the second debate.
We have never Trump or is a host, but that's
OK because it beat him in the second debate
also.
And but I'm not going to do a virtual debate.
So, you know, so, Mr. President, you're not
going to do it because the CPD, the Commission
on Presidential Debates announcing this morning
that the second presidential debate will be
virtual.
You're saying you're not going to participate?
No, I'm not going to waste my time in a virtual
debate.
That's not what debating is all about.
You sit behind a computer and do a debate
is ridiculous.
And then they cut you off whenever they want.
Trump seemingly at the end there admitting
what this is really about.
They can cut you off whenever they want.
Which Donald Trump doesn't want because his
strategy is to just keep talking.
Most importantly, keep interrupting Joe Biden
speculatively.
The idea is that Trump believes, maybe accurately,
that constantly interrupting Joe Biden will
work will wreak havoc with Joe Biden, struggling
with a stutter his whole life.
And that it is really you're not arguing the
issues when your idea is to just keep interrupting
the other the other candidate.
And now it starts to get wacky where Maria
Bartiromo just can't control Trump.
And we're going to look at this in the next
segment.
But listen to this.
I have a host, too, I always thought was a
nice guy, but I see is a never Trumper came
out.
That is a never Trumper.
We do have some of them, Maria.
Believe it or not, because I don't like to
win and I'm sorry, but I'm not going.
And very pointedly, they didn't even tell
us about when Faren Cough was asked about
Trump not participating.
He said that it's totally Trump's right.
There there is no law requiring a presidential
candidate to debate.
Frank Fahrenkopf said that in 1980, Jimmy
Carter refused to participate in the first
debate.
Later participated in the second debate.
And the commission essentially saying it's
up to the candidate to decide, do they want
to debate or do they not want to debate?
So as of right now, and forgive me if this
has changed, it's possible the commission
will change their plan.
It's possible Trump will change his mind.
Anything could happen.
But as of right now, debate two scheduled
to be remote and Donald Trump will not participate
in that second debate.
And it's amazing how everything has come back.
You know, we talk about projection from the
from the Trump lists and how all of these
things they accuse others of are things they
are doing themselves.
For months now, Trump has been saying Biden
will bail Don Junior.
Others saying Biden's going to find a way
out because Biden just can't do it.
And it's actually Donald Trump who has been
the first to say, I'm not going to participate
in a debate.
I don't really know how much it will hurt
him.
Listen, the other reality is the first debate
really hurt Trump.
Trump's polling fell off a cliff.
The day after the first debate, we started
to see a rapid ascent for Joe Biden and a
rapid decline for Donald Trump.
So it almost might be better for Trump not
to debate from the standpoint of not doing
even more damage by participating.
It's certainly true that not given the chance
to interrupt constantly, which may be Trump
wouldn't be given if indeed the debate was
done in a remote format.
It could be even worse for Donald Trump.
So maybe he will end up participating.
It's also conceivable that the CPD will come
to some agreement that there was an idea thrown
around that they would move the debate outdoors
and have sort of a big covered area where
it's outdoors and socially distanced with
plexiglass.
I still think it's conceivable that in the
next day or two somebody proposes that and
they say, given that we've been able to move
the debate outdoors and account for this,
that and the other thing, that they'll do
it in person again.
It could happen.
It might not.
There might be no second debate.
I don't know how it's all going to go.
Does it turn into a Joe Biden town hall if
Donald Trump simply doesn't participate or
do they cancel the event altogether?
I don't know.
But next, I want to look at some other clips
from this interview that Trump did this morning.